edouard husson comment fédérer justement
c'est des classes et on sait que joe
biden a beaucoup mis l'accent voilà
aussi sur les minorités l'unité
notamment jusque dans les membres de son
gouvernement il faudra aller chercher
cette classe blanche des classes est
peut-être celle qu'on a vue sur les
marches du capitole très en colère il
faudra revenir les ap alors que l'on
voit donc joe biden qui est à pierre
avec sa famille qui se dirige vers la
maison blanche ça va être compliqué
justement de fédérer cette amérique en
colère je prends ce qui va être ce qui
va être très difficile si vous voulez
dans les mois et les années qui viennent
c'est c'est de sortir des clichés au
sens où bon si vous voulez on a des
discours on a des représentations
il ya une espèce de instinctive de
beaucoup de médias a tramp mais quand
vous regardez son bilan économique il
est bien meilleur que ce qu'on dit savez
vous que le le la part du revenu des 1%
puisqu'on en parle souvent a diminué
dans l'ensemble des revenus des
américains pendant alors pendant les
quatre ans qui viennent de s'écouler
alors c'est pas spectaculaires ces
quelques décile de points mais si vous
voulez c'est un fait savez vous que la
le taux de pauvreté absolue 5e quintile
du taux de pauvreté est passé en dessous
des 10% pour la première fois depuis
longtemps
savez vous que le niveau de vie de la
population noire et le est le plus fort
depuis les années 1970
donc si vous voulez je crois qu'il va
falloir sortir nous allons aussi devoir
sortir d'un discours manichéen sur les
états unis
tran pas été du point de vue des
résultats un bon président il a fait du
bien à l'économie il a créé énormément
d'emplois le l'emploi a rebondi après la
crise du coc vide alors ensuite joe
biden part sur des bases assez saine
économiquement que l'ua que lui a
laissés trump et que fera t-il c'est
difficile c'est difficile de le savoir
mais il faut surtout pas tomber dans le
cliché comme quoi les démocrates
seraient les candidats de des classes
des classes populaires et
et sauf les blancs pas du tout yahia il
ya énormément de gens extrêmement riches
aux états unis qui ont voté pour les
démocrates ou l'establishment financier
à voter pour lui on voit revenir des
anciens de l'équipe obama dont vous
voyez je crois qu'il va falloir sortir
des clichés
l'amérique est très complexe elle est
très divisée il ya une classe moyenne
qui n'existent qui a existé de moins en
moins dans les années 2000 et 2010 trump
avait pensé à voir la manière de la
reconstituer peut-être at-il échoué ça
les historiens le diront mais en tout
cas
by donne va avoir très fort à faire si
je reviens sur le plan politique si vous
voulez il a une aile gauche très
radicale très militante et qui va le qui
va le pousser soi pour faire plaisir à
bernie sanders ce soit pour répondre à
des à un agenda idéologique à s'éloigner
du centre or on ne peut réconcilier
qu'au centre